the premise of the movie is set in the
year 1958 a young woman named rose lives
in normandy with her father she works as
a cashier at a family-owned grocery
store but is ambitious about doing
something better in life with the same
dream in mind she applies for a job as a
secretary in an insurance office many
women have lined up for the interview
which makes rose nervous moreover they
chat about proper interview attire and
etiquette that rose was completely
oblivious to prior to this the owner of
the company louis is a kind-hearted but
stern man when it is rose's turn she
gets to meet him on being asked about
her strengths she claims that she is
very good at typing but since it is the
minimum requirement for a job like this
she is turned down louis walks to the
door to invite another candidate inside
but rose refuses to give up that easily
she pulls a typewriter over and starts
typing at a great speed with only two
fingers when she is done her hair's a
mess and the strap of her dress has
moved the two look at each other unable
to deny the sexual tension amazed by
rose's skill and beauty louis hires her
imagine a world where typing fast gets
you laid that day rose returns home in
excitement but her father doesn't allow
her to move to the city for work he
wants her to get married to a local rich
mechanic rose defies her father's wish
and runs away from home the next morning
in the city she stays at a women's
hostel and begins going to work louis
soon starts to regret his decision
because rose types the entire day making
tapping noises that are too loud for him
to focus she is also not good at
anything other than typing across from
louie's office is his friend bob's
architectural firm hence the two get to
hang out with each other often bob
notices that rose's presence has started
to bother louie in the evening louis
goes to bob's home where they have
organized a birthday party for him bob's
wife marie used to be louie's sweetheart
before he went to war they are still
good friends but louis never stopped
loving her even though she is married to
his best friend and has two children as
days pass louie gets to see more sides
to rose she is very unprofessional but
completes the job at the end of the day
anytime he tries to make fun of her she
has a snarky comment ready to go a week
into working together louie sits her
down and tells her that she hasn't been
an ideal secretary he suggests she do
something more personal in order to
prove her worth rose assumes the worst
and storms off refusing to get into bed
with him but louie follows her to
explain what he means he wants her to
take part in the typing competition for
women sure that's what he meant if she
is able to win she can continue working
for him louis sees real talent in rose
and wants to be the one to support her
when ben finds out about this he laughs
at louis he thinks it is better to sleep
with a secretary than to enroll her in a
competition that does him no good
however louis ignores his suggestion
knowing that rose will be a hit if given
an opportunity on the day of the
competition rose is nervous the women
she is competing against are
professionals who have been practicing
for months the tournament starts and she
instantly struggles to place the paper
on the typewriter and change it the
other women are using all their fingers
unlike her who is used to typing only
with her index fingers in the end she is
only two words short of qualifying for
the next round on the car ride back home
she cries and asks to be let out later
that day louie goes to meet her in the
hostel and invites her to live at his
home he wants to train her so she can
compete in the next tournament that is
in three months if she agrees she gets
to keep her job as well rose thinks
about it for a minute before accepting
then she moves in with him but the two
decide to keep it a secret her training
starts on the very first day louie makes
her paint her nails a certain color and
assigns the color to a part of the
typewriter that way she knows what
finger to use for what letter initially
rose thinks it is too much work but
louis monitors her every move making
sure she is not trying to cheat him by
using her old method she is made to
train for hours alongside working as his
secretary this causes her to make
several mistakes at work but louis
teaches her a lesson every time the two
return home separately so people won't
suspect they are living together one
afternoon on louie's way back home he
notices rose falling off her bike he
goes to help her and cannot help but to
notice that her top is see-through the
next day he finds rose's bra inside the
washer instead of making it awkward he
goes to a room to place it himself yeah
that's not awkward he is caught in the
act but rose laughs it off and jokes
about buying him a pair a few more days
pass of them living together louis cooks
sometimes which rose thinks is
interesting some days the exhaustion
gets the best of her so he gives her a
gentle massage they both feel the sparks
between them but hide their feelings
behind playful insults one afternoon
louis goes to marie begging her to give
rose piano lessons he thinks that
learning to play the piano will be good
for her typing speed when marie refuses
he manipulates her by trying to hurt
himself rose notices the special
closeness between them while dressing
louie's wound she calls him out for
bragging to another man's wife louis
just smiles at her for an answer
starting the next day the typing lessons
are followed by piano lessons and a one
mile run every day when it is finally
the day of the local level competition
rose comes first in every round and
reaches the finale to prepare for the
next match her nail polish and the color
on the typewriter are removed louis
times her every time she types and is
glad to see that she is making progress
then for the final match she and the
opponent face each other in a fierce
competition louis holds his breath when
it is announced that rose is the new
normandy typewriting champion with 491
keystrokes per minute ben loses the bet
and has to hand his entire wallet to his
friend louie and rose hug enjoy they
have finally proven themselves as a
competent teacher and student the
following day at work everyone is
praising rose louis has brought a
bouquet of red roses for her but prior
to him another man gives her the same
thing he also invites her to dinner at
night but louis interrupts them saying
that she still has to train for the
national level competition in the
meantime marie and rose have also
developed a friendship marie wants the
best for louie and thinks he is meant to
be with rose on her birthday rose is sad
that her father didn't send her a letter
but at night louie surprises her with a
cake that sends her over the moon he
also gives her a handmade typewriter
cover that will help her type without
looking at the keys upon seeing the gift
rose realizes it is not for her but for
himself she feels like everything louis
does is to prove that he is a good
person because if not he wouldn't have
given her the cover when she is tired of
practicing for hours every day they get
into an argument before she goes to her
room later he asks her to go home on
christmas because his family will come
over rose suggests she can act like his
maid but louis urges her to leave as
soon as possible with no other choice
rose goes back to her town however her
father refuses to meet her after
spending hours beside her mother's grave
she decides to go to marie's place upon
finding out that louie asked her to go
away marie is furious she drives rose to
his house and introduces her as his
fiancee to his parents rose is welcomed
and treated like family she and louis
have to act like lovers but they do not
seem to mind during dinner louie's
father criticizes him for being too weak
because he prioritizes customers more
than money rose speaks in favor of her
boss asking his father to be more like
his son the gesture makes louie feel a
warm sensation in his heart during
supper he dances with rose and carries
her to bed because she is drunk rose
asks him to join her but louie laughs it
off saying that they aren't married yet
the next day louie is at ben's marie
makes him reveal that he and rose
haven't kissed which wins her 10 bucks
from ben louie is mad that they bet on
his and rose's relationship when he
retaliates marie simply states that he
has fallen in love with rose a week
later louie and rose go to paris to take
part in the national level typing
competition rose goes to the beauty
parlor eager to compete with the divas
of paris she returns home at night in a
seductive red dress louis cannot take
his eyes off of her but stops himself
from doing anything stupid since when
did the french show anywhere near this
level of restraint he thinks their
relationship will distract her from the
match tomorrow rose argues that nothing
of such sort will happen they lock lips
for a kiss and end up making love in the
following scene we are introduced to the
three-time national typewriting champion
annie she boasts about her unbeatable
talent and is confident she will win
this year as well the competition starts
and both annie and rose do their best in
the end they make it to the final round
the match is intense and the results
astonish everyone both of them have
typed exactly 498 keystrokes per minute
a 5 minute extra time is added so the
judges can come to a decision during the
break time louis tells rose that she is
doing worse than training they get into
an argument that fuels her will to win
louie is happy because this is exactly
why he provoked her for the last round
he goes outside unable to watch the
fierce match annie tries to stare rose
down but she fights back harder in the
end louis hears people cheering and runs
to the stage to see his secretary
celebrating his eyes tear up as he
watches her smiling in pure happiness
but just then the head organizer tells
him that he has to leave rose if he
wants her to win the international
competition louis knows he is telling
the truth because his presence is a
distraction to her the same night rose
tells him that she loves him louis feels
his pain multiply at the confession
because he loves her too but isn't able
to confess he tells her that he only
slept with her so that she would win the
competition rose refuses to believe him
but he leaves paris without her leaving
the poor girl heartbroken although
depressed rose has to star in
commercials and attend several press
conferences she turns into a national
celebrity overnight she gets a letter
from her father saying that he is proud
of her many powerful men fawn over her
but she continues calling louie every
night he too is suffering as much as her
he brings a random woman home but cannot
bring himself to sleep with her then he
goes to marie and asks her why she chose
ben instead of him marie replies that
she felt loved when she was with ben but
louis was ready to sacrifice her to go
to war even though he wanted her to be
happy he never fought to be with her
louis realizes he is doing the same
thing with rose and decides to fly to
america in the meantime rose is in
america representing france in the
international typewriting competition
she is going against the american record
holder who has remained undefeated her
entire career the match will be
completed in two rounds in the first one
rose is so nervous that she loses by a
large gap during the break she runs
backstage and is surprised to see louie
he confesses that he loves her back and
motivates her to do her best rose uses
her old typewriter and is determined to
win the last round it starts and rose
types like she has been possessed making
the opponent nervous in the middle of it
her typewriter malfunctions but she
fixes it quickly and continues despite
the obstacle rose wins and is awarded
the world's fastest typist louis could
not be more proud of her the movie ends
as they kiss and the entire crowd cheers
for them remember kids if you want to
get with your crush just abduct them
make them run a mile every day and force
them into a competition that they don't
even care about subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching